la mobilisation aujourd'hui également
des gilets jaunes avec comme
revendication la demande de plus de
justice sociale mais aussi la lutte
contre les violences policières et le
racisme ils ont eu l'interdiction se
rassembler sur les champs elysées aux
alentours le mouvement s'était lancé ce
matin de la porte dorée dans le 12e
arrondissement est direction la gare du
nord c'est toujours la même la même
chose que les revendications de base
mais moi personnellement je suis sur le
plus souvent sorti et à chaque fois
c'est pour protester contre les
violences policières en général parce
que ça me samuel serre de voir que dans
le pays des policiers agissent comme ça
même si évidemment il ya des policiers
qui font leur travail correctement
mais dans les manifestations j'arrive
pas à comprendre que que les policiers
considèrent le citoyen qui manifestent
comme un délinquant un ca de 10 et
rappeler à ces gouvernorats qui les
sachant que les jets les gens sont
encore là donc ils sont autistes
donc on utilise la méthode coué pour le
rappeler à leur bon souvenir mais par
contre il est grand temps je suis un peu
un appel à mes frères et soeurs gilet
jaune de de revoir la stratégie
les gilet jaune là existe toujours on
tient à le montrer qu'on l'a montré
depuis un certain temps
toutes les luttes se valent et notamment
sur les violences policières
d'ailleurs je voudrais faire un point il
ya violence policière et violences
policières raciste ce ne sont pas les
mêmes elles s'additionnent et à propos
de violences policières je pense que ça
va très bien se passer aujourd'hui parce
que il suffira de dire on est tchétchène
et ils nous laisseront passer même si on
sort des armes on dit on et tchétchènes
forcément ils vont nous laisser passer